Well,
hello, how are you? Sal and Jaramillo greet you
with the briefing for today, Tuesday
, May 25. The NTSB is
investigating a fatal accident
involving a fighter plane near
the Neil Air Base. The identity of the
deceased pilot has not been revealed.  revealed yet
however the base says it was
being operated by a civilian contractor
the pilot was alone on this plane which he
cleared from the base and crashed
around 2:30
p.m. yesterday on property near
several club casinos  and tension continue to
hire staff to
meet the demand close to the nation day,
for example, this will have
another work day today at the
golden gate ballet starting at 9 in the
morning, you must apply for the position prior to
attending this event,
interviews will be held  right there totally from
the comfort of your vehicle for a
complete list of jobs visit
kirchner dotcom diagonal en español
boy gaming also offers a faith
labor ria today in the gold coast this event
will be from 1 to 4 in the afternoon the company is
looking to hire for more than 100 positions
you can fill out your application at bikers
dotcom now we pass with
the weather forecast a day with maximum sun and clouds is expected
it will be in the low 90
degrees as well as winds between 20 and 30
miles per hour have a good day I
am salt and jaramillo with your brief
informative for them now in Spanish